when president biden took office the  deficit over the next 10 years was  expected to be about 12.2 trillion  dollars thanks to a boatload of new  spending approved during biden's first  year that's climbed to  14.5 trillion one way or another that  shortfall has to be accounted for by  cutting spending raising taxes or  printing money so what does the new  inflation reduction act do to address  the problem it doesn't cut unnecessary  spending or wasteful government programs  it raises taxes and those tax increases  will only reduce the deficit by about  300 billion dollars or two percent of  planned borrowing over the next 10 years  in other words even assuming no new  spending we'd still need about 50 more  bills just like this one to not add any  more debt in the next decade and the  bill doesn't do anything to reduce the  30 trillion dollars in debt we've  already accumulated